you go after folks in your book yeah
don't hesitate now all people down you
call it Lady Gaga yep you feel like her
anti-bullying campaign is a ruse for
trying to promote her liberal agenda yes
it you go why do you think that well
because it's true it is and that's what
Hollywood does Hollywood pushes a
liberal agenda to the rest of the
country and whether we like it or not
Hollywood dictates the culture of the
country but why don't you think her
agenda is pure because if it was then it
wouldn't have brought up all that other
stuff you know all the other things I
came in wouldn't have come into play it
would have just been this is what I want
to say and this is it you also call out
Caitlyn Jenner yeah but she she's a
concern yeah yeah but I think I think
that you know she's saying she wants to
go into the women's bathroom she's a
woman now go into the woman's bathroom
but why it's tyranny by the minority why
do I have to suffer because you can't
decide what you want to be that day but
is it a decision I I would think so it's
your body so it's your decision right we
all have we all make choices I guess a
lot of people in the transgender
community would then say it is Who I am
and I don't choose to be one way or
another it's who I okay then go go to
the bushes I don't know what to tell you
I'm not gonna put my child's life at
risk because you want to change a law so
that you can be comfortable with your
beliefs which means I have to change my
beliefs and my rights No well isn't this
a world though of compromise I mean how
do we get to a place of who all of us
don't compromise
until it starts to infringe upon my
rights too much then no have you always
been this way so steadfast yeah so
straightener did you evolve no well
that's what I got out of where I
wouldn't be here right now if I wasn't